hey youtubers is Charlie so if you guys
didn't know Game of Thrones just became
like the most winningest TV show in the
history of awards that it's possible for
TV shows to win we also see a bunch of
actors rolling up to the season 7 set so
we'll start with the award stuff then
I'll talk about season 7 stuff careful
for spoilers for everything that's
happened so far most of you won't be
surprised at all the Game of Thrones is
winning so many Emmys if you didn't know
there's like two big different kinds of
Emmys there's like the Primetime Emmys
where most of the actors when there are
awards for performances directors best
episodes when Best Drama wins an award
like Game of Thrones itself wins an
award for being the best drama that year
but then there are the creative Emmys
for like all the technical things like
the costumes the big fight scenes so
yeah that big episode 9 battle of the
bastards big pitch battle naturally it's
like a nightmare scenario trying to
organize all that just let alone get the
performances out of the actors so Game
of Thrones not only has some of the best
actors in the world winning awards for
their performances the best directors
the best people behind the camera it
also has some of the best technical
people making like the little things
that you don't always notice the best
thing ever so it's a long ways off but
next year like the big thing that people
were talking about this past year during
the awards season because they're
starting so late and the season is going
to premiere so much later in the year
they're gonna miss the cutoff date for
next year's awards season so Game of
Thrones won't be eligible no matter how
good it is it won't be eligible for
Emmys next year they'll have to submit
all the stuff they're shooting now for
awards the year after next year
so I know it sounds weird it's not
really that big a deal they want so many
awards they could melt them down and
make an Iron Throne just out of Emmys
awards that's like a Saturday Night Live
sketch like Danny Dave after this past
year like they had this funny skit where
they were sitting in their office with
just piles of money sitting all around
next time it's going to be a throne of
Emmys but on a season 7 stuff so the
Watchers people like the people that
have been following all the castings
have noticed that they've already shot a
scene with Joran Greyjoy based on some
of the stuff that's happening with the
Ironborn storyline so fewer episode
count as we all know means that they're
going to get to that faster
part of the bargain that theon and Yara
made with Daenerys in order to help her
get to Westeros with her troops was that
she helped them get rid of Euron so what
will seem like no surprise now that
Cersei will actually be entering into a
Faustian bargain with Euron because
everybody else hates both of them so
much
Euron is one of the only people on the
show right now who is worse than Cersei
and if you weren't sure like you haven't
read the books there's this scene that
george RR martin teased four winds of
winter where the damp hair who's one of
the other brothers of Balon Greyjoy is
one of Euron's brothers is remembering
being abused as a child sexually abused
by Euron who then goes on to have
visions of Euron sitting on the Iron
Throne in a suit of Valyrian armor so
your honor traveled all over the world
so a lot of people know about dragon
binder the Valyrian horned is supposedly
when blown gives him control over
dragons so maybe we'll see that in
season 7 maybe not but the more
important thing is that the damp air is
seeing this nightmare scenario where
you're on becomes like the big big
villain of the show someone who's way
worse than Ramsay Bolton and what could
be worse than Ramsay Bolton then an
alliance between Cersei who just
absolutely does not care about anything
anymore she does she'll do anything in
someone who's cut from that same villain
cloth like you're on so if the two of
them were to team up then it just open
season on everybody else it's going to
be ridiculous so what I'm hoping for
from this Euron storyline because
there's really two parts of this
you have Cersei in King's Landing like
she's not going to leave King's Landing
she's gonna be holed up in the red key
but Euron's power is it see what I'm
hoping is is that we have a giant pitch
battle at sea but let me know in the
comments do you actually think that they
will do a big sea battle with the iron
but you know between Yara and Euron's
forces because they said going into
season six one of the things they wanted
to do that they had not done yet was a
giant pitch battle episode and that's
kind of how the idea for the Battle of
the bastards episode came about they're
like you know we haven't done a big
battle episode like that so like the
next thing that they could do that check
off their list of like really awesome
episodes would be a big sea
like a really big battle now they did
have Blackwater but that wasn't so much
a battle as much a massacre
they just Trojan horse in a ship full of
wildfire and it just set off the entire
fleet so that wasn't like a big battle
in the sense the Battle of the bastards
was a battle episode but as I said most
of the main actors have arrived back in
Belfast to start filming season seven so
like you have Samwell you have Jon Snow
you have Cersei there even sand snakes
that are now back in Belfast so there
will be some door and sand snake stuff
happening but this is really just the
beginning they're going to be filming
all through the rest of the year so
we'll probably see some really cool
stuff from behind the scenes in the next
couple of months
so get hype it's gonna be awesome but if
you guys didn't know there is a game of
Thrones giveaway that's going on all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video it's just
a $20 Amazon gift card so now that we've
started seeing stuff from behind the
scenes I can start planning some of my
bonus videos so I'll try to plan around
some of the stuff that it actually looks
like they're doing so we'll talk about
some euron greyjoy we'll talk about some
Cersei Lannister I know everybody's
still wondering about winds of winter -
now that's like separate book stuff so
as we hear more stuff about the book
release day I'll be doing book videos
too but that'll be like a little bit
different from the TV show videos so
next was probably happen is is there's
new Ghost Rider footage for agents of
shield there's some new spider-man
homecoming like dance behind the scenes
stuff I might do a video for that just
because it's so much fun
spider-man starring in Marvel's version
of the get-down so lots of awesome stuff
coming later today while you guys wait
for them to post you can click here to
watch that season 7 teaser trailer again
you can click here for Avengers infinity
war behind the scenes thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you